[Music]
what is it
that makes an esports caster legendary
is it their innate ability to just
perfectly capture
exactly what you're feeling you see
double smokes in the same place they're
simple just jumping casually to the side
he's going to fall down again
what is this simple are you serious what
is that you can't do that simple that's
not allowed this is not fpl this is a
major
or maybe it's their tendency to
improvise that
raises the hair on the back of your neck
adam
can you do it here is it our fell
he gets the goal of his lifetime
oh guardian bye bye and it's on to
flamey he's tapped in flames
what in god's name is that from stacks
unbelievable or maybe it's their
capacity to string together words almost
effortlessly into phrases
that transcend the very games they're
casting
happy feet
[Music]
but what if they brought something to
casting that's often overlooked
what have they brought themselves well
in european league of legends you'll
have a hard time finding
anyone who's more comfortable in his own
skin
than andrew vedius day a
wacky welsh caster who has successfully
carved out his own niche using cringe
humor
analysis and of course his boundless
personality it's done it's done and it
is
done all you need is pressure
i love the french bread but vedius's
unique spin on casting
wasn't always everyone's cup of tea in
fact
in the beginning it wasn't really
anyone's
so how is it that this larger than
league showman helped to not only break
the casting meta
but redefine it and more importantly
how did he manage to do that whilst
battling the two-headed beast that is
self-doubt and community backlash
hello everyone i'm shoxius and taking
over the show with me today is
fulvius and detective the vedius hello
there
dear sharksus it is a pleasure to be
here on this fine day
okay guys so before we dive into this
league of legends offbeat that i am
being forced to present against my will
i must ask you to please like the video
subscribe to the channel
and turn on notifications so you get to
watch any and all of our future offbeats
as soon as they go live alright so if
there is one thing that can be said for
vedius
it is that he is a man of many faces
perhaps you know him as
flexius maybe you've seen him in a dress
as shaksis
in the kitchen as shepheus or the dojo
as foldeas your first encounter could
have been with explanaius
or maybe you saw him solving crimes as
vedius the detective
and even when he's not playing a
character he's always
well he's always a bit of a character
just tune in not only do we have the
best league of legends players in the
world
we've also got the best content on the
market i'm on a horse
it's easy to get lost in his sea of
alter egos
but what about the vedius the real one
is it even possible to pin down this
comedic shapeshifter
well vedius hails from the country of
wales
which isn't exactly the mecca of esports
it's most famous for being home to tom
jones
stunning scenery and difficult to
pronounce
place names one of those places is
vedius's home
town of clandello
did i do that right clandello today i'm
in
chandelor in lovely camardinshire
nailed it anyway
vedius was recommended league of legends
by a friend
back in season one during his first year
of university where he picked up
brand and grew more and more invested in
the game
but as the seasons rolled by vedius
began to realize that he had less
interest in pursuing his psychology
degree
and began to toy with the idea of going
pro
in league however we see the flash away
from not trying to play movement very
low prince philip the target here comes
vedios and here come excel what can they
do our tours gets taken down by prince
philip who will go down though
red movement very low dan helps pick up
the kill on
to nocturnal flex and here comes videos
trying to do as much as he can but it's
2v3
and orianna coming in as well the
binding not gonna connect and xl took
the fight
and although he was good vedius realized
that his real talent
lay not in playing amateur league but
rather
in casting it he honed his craft at esl
premiership games and tournaments
such as insomnia and it's here where his
passion
knowledge and growing confidence began
to come together
he is so familiar with it he knows how
to play it his positioning is on point
just take it ban it i don't care just
stop giving it to him and in 2016
when ryde announced that the eu lcs was
moving from a best-of-one
to a best-of-two format which would
require more casters
vetia saw an opportunity to throw his
name into the mix
and after applying for a position
vedius's family
enlisted the help of a neighbor to make
sure that he didn't sleep through his
interview
she then lets herself in because she has
a key from my nan
and she is shouting right she's
literally chatting with the thickest
welsh accent you've ever heard right she
is going
wonder love i've heard that you've got
an interview today and i've come to make
sure that you're awake
and then i am i'm like furiously
apologize in the quick shot
right and i'm like i'm really sorry as
vedius waited what felt like an eternity
to hear back
he received two other permanent casting
offers
one to cast korean league for spo tv
and another to cast vainglory
remember vainglory never heard of it but
as appealing as those offers were to
vetius his heart was entirely set on
europe
although at the time it wasn't entirely
clear that europe
was set on him it was surprisingly quite
mixed a few people didn't want me and i
don't blame them
my knowledge back then was not very good
it was very much that of a diamond one
solo queue player so i didn't really
have great pro player insights but
props to quick shot quick shot said that
i think this guy has like really insane
potential and i think that um he can be
like a really valuable
asset so quick shot match for me they
believed in quick shots vouch and so
they ended up hiring me for
some splits and in june of 2016 he
officially made his
first lcs broadcast appearance of course
a new member of the lcs crew here
vedius you've done challenger but what
does it feel like to be on the lcs
summer split start it's a little bit
nerve-wracking but i'm really excited to
see what these lcs teams bring out on
this
um pretty amazing patch vedius joined an
established cast of
seasoned broadcast veterans and former
pro players like deficio and krepo
who had seamlessly transitioned their
experience as high level competitors
into their role as color casters they
were able to translate the 200 iq pro
plays into a language that
even the most yasuo meaning turret
diving no mini map looking bronze player
could understand
and that was something that vettius felt
he just wasn't ready to do because i
still felt
like that i wasn't a great caster
especially in knowledge and the thing is
um i really did feel a lot of pressure
when it came to like leveling up my
knowledge because the problem is i
didn't know how to get smarter
and the guys didn't really know how to
teach me how to get smarter because they
just lived it you know
they were pro players their experience
was just being a pro player
it wasn't like natural to me whereas to
those two it was just like
it was obvious almost but has very
struggled to meet his
own standards for casting he soon
discovered that his
greatest challenge would lie in winning
over the league community with his
particular approach
focus make him public
to be more purple is to be a greater
individual
obviously a lot of people really didn't
like it a lot of people thought that it
was very cringe
a lot of people thought it was super
distracting a lot of people thought that
it was just very annoying and it
like took away from the game but every
time
you would see people talking about the
casters they would go
crapload official videos and that was
the goal right
it didn't matter because the point is
that they knew who videos was and they
might have hated vader
vedius we could fix that later racked
with self-doubt and casting to a
sometimes hostile audience someone else
may have buckled under the pressure
but you wouldn't be watching this video
of edius and caved in
while he tried to play catch-up on the
analysis side of things
vettius began to explore a skill that
came more naturally to him than most
others his talent for showmanship
picks to watch was vedius's first
segment he had all to himself
the idea was simple he'd break down the
champions that viewers should expect to
see each week
it was a solid idea but his producer
margot
laurier felt it needed just a little
more spice
the intro was her idea so she said
uh i think this content is kind of
boring
and also people don't know who you are
so we need something to capture them
so that they will click on the link and
then hopefully they'll stay for the
video so we kind of want clickbait right
and i was like okay cool uh and so she's
like so i think we should do something
just a little bit funny and if you look
at the first one the very first one
it's kind of relatively tame so this is
kind of where the betty then comes in
so like in the first one i'm like okay
so i understand the playground that i'm
working with now
and then like the natural betty park
just kind of came out and i was like
let's be weird wonderful the intros were
bizarre
quirky and sometimes barely made sense
but crucially they were vedious to a t
but as authentic to the man as they
might have been the reactions to them
were mixed and at a certain point even
margot thought that they might be
getting a bit too weird
she was like maybe we should you know
because now they're like a little
too far and i was like no i think that's
why people watch the videos margot i'm
going to keep doing them
but he wouldn't have to fight with the
battle alone for long
because it was when vedius found himself
being paired with the equally
charismatic
medic that content and casting sparks
truly began to fly it's merry fairy
merry ready time
but yes i didn't ask you this yesterday
but will you be my valentine of course
my friend how could i not kiss me betty
no
hey slowly but surely
vedius's unique brand was beginning to
win over the community
but the amazing part is that it wasn't
just fans who'd been won over by his
shenanigans
when the eu lcs decided to rebrand as
the lec
in 2019 it wasn't just a name change
the production team looked to vetius as
inspiration for their new head-turning
approach to broadcasting league
that didn't take itself too seriously if
you had worked at riot for a while
it was really hard to break out of the
mindset of like this is esports
professionalism it's
really hard to break out of that but he
bless his heart
is just so unashamedly himself and so he
started pitching weird stuff and so
venice isn't like
the sole mastermind behind this but by
being the kind of person that no matter
what
else has like come before no matter what
the context he's always willing to like
put himself out there and pitch this
wild stuff
it really like kicked off everyone's
creativity
instead of the standard wooden pre and
post game segments notorious across
all of esports the lec hard pivoted in
the complete opposite direction
and while some of their offering was
still somewhat cringe
at least it was designed to be that way
but we're gonna take him out have a
doubt he'll be showing up killed him in
lane such a shame goldie going up i
don't want to hear about pokes he don't
matter to me
send him up against hans give him that
easy yo-3
and while some of the early rap battles
may have started out
intentionally mediocre pretty soon
memes aside they actually kind of
slapped
bad drafts it's bad reads it's mickey's
wrist it's just greed
when are you gonna admit your boys are
just playing like [ __ ]
with europe reaching the world's finals
two years in a row
eu pride was at an all-time high vetius
and co
continued to give european fans the
soundtrack to reflect this wave of
euphoria the whole war trying just to
look like us take a look at julie wish
he played like
us nantana shook reality you're facing a
tragedy when the european legacy comes
[ __ ] down your path to be those
feelings of anxiety the future you don't
want to see the wrath of our whole
dynasty spells lec
in fact even people who didn't play or
watch league
knew an absolute banger when they saw
one
put your hands together if you all
remember me here for the best years
2015 and once you're a rap god
where do you go next well if you said
emo rock well done
[Music]
eu used to be a region that struggled to
find its identity
to separate itself from its equally dull
north american sibling but with this
winning combination of music and memes
the lec has been able to
carve out a unique personality that's
become the envy of league of legends
production around the world
now of course goofing around and doing
skits is all well and good
but it doesn't matter if your casting
isn't up to scratch
but since joining in 2016 vedius had
grown
so much as a caster that his efforts
were rewarded when he was chosen to cast
the grand
finals at worlds a fantastic performance
throughout this series
and now they are just being dismantled
by
dom one another double kill goes into
the back pockets of ghost
they have the baron buff they're looking
to break into the bay vedius had reached
the pinnacle
and more importantly he did it his way
he helped to turn the european
production that told him to tone it down
into an extension of his unique and
irreplaceable brand of comedy
and in the process not only had he
liberated himself
from the shackles of convention but his
colleagues as well
there were a couple of weeks where i
just was so excited and i hadn't
had that feeling necessarily for a few
years because i always loved doing the
show
but this getting up and being like i
want to go to the studio and make the
best show possible is going to be
freaking amazing
we're making a show that people are
excited to watch as much as we are
excited to make it
look there's clearly a wealth of
talented people behind the songs
behind the skits behind everything that
fans have come to adore
about the lec over the years even more
of them work
behind the camera to bring the lec to
life
but if you had to trace it back if you
had to search in the lec's dna
to find why it feels like you're
watching league with a goofy and
knowledgeable friend that
doesn't take themselves too seriously
you'd probably stumble
upon a crazy welshman who smashed
through
a wall of cringe and came face to face
with himself on the other side i've
always wanted to be
like an estee caster i've always wanted
to be considered
like a papa smithy or a deficio or
a caster that's kind of like live
without the ages and if i was to leave i
would like to think a lot of people
would sit there and say like
i miss betty as a caster but i think
that just because of
who i am and where like because i'm not
a pro player i don't think i'll ever
achieve that
which kind of sucks but at the same time
i know that i do have a lot of fans out
there that like
enjoy what i do and i think as a result
of that i've also just made the lacy
better you know
[Music]
which tom jones are we talking about we
talk about the literary character are we
talking about like the singer tom jones
i was gonna say i don't think that tom
jones the literary character hails from
wales
no he's from somerset saumerset somerset
yeah fielding was born in somerset